are we gonna call you that now the
selfie queen of Canada I've heard that
but I would never comb that myself out
on my own
okay people have said that do you like
that title of course why not
yeah and selfies are part of life it's
like a way of life mm-hmm it's a way of
life it's a way of your life right now
so should your gonna be competing are
you gonna be taking a selfie before you
get on the court I mean before I match I
definitely keep my focus and I'm not on
snapchat or Instagram or anything like
that
after sometimes for sure I'll be showing
I don't know my cooldown how I'm feeling
after I play and then obviously on my
days off I'm just kind of taking
pictures of everything yeah and what do
you think it is about your life that
people love so much because you have a
huge following you have over a million
right yeah I don't know what they like I
hope they just enjoy following you know
what I do yeah I try to kind of show
people what they maybe normally wouldn't
see from a normal tournament or from you
know just the media I would want to show
kind of behind the scenes you know if
I'm on the massage table after my match
you know like no one sees that except
for me and my therapist so I like to
show kind of different things that I
love to see in you know celebs I like to
follow you know the stuff no one gets to
see sure one of us loves you like to
follow the Kardashians you did something
very cover for Halloween where you you
kind of showed your assets it's like Kim
Kardashian yeah I don't know how I got
that idea it literally just popped into
my head and I did it with a friend of
mine and as a joke we also tried having
the bars with but with actually nothing
like actually being naked and we were
like this cannot go anywhere this is
like porn so we were like I am knocking
us that put this on the Internet's but
the point was to exaggerate it and
they'll get funny so we got like yeah
these kind of Spanx and literally I put
towels in my hips and I put some of my
socks that I used to play in my bra and
tried to create kids figure sure you but
you did such a great job at recreating
her figure so did you wake up the next
morning and say oh my goodness that's
how these people liking this pic it's
it's always a surprise to me you and
that things kind of go viral or people
really pay attention because at the end
of the day I almost still consider it
like I'm showing my friends what I'm
doing and you know
it's just what all my friends do so I
consider myself normal like that and oh
look at my costume and then I realized
like oh yeah like people might actually
pay more attention and I care and they
might make articles about it so I don't
have to be careful but it's always a
surprise to me even my other costume I
kind of did this cat thing and people
assumed it was a real costume but it was
a complete tank I mean I literally
bought five dollar cat years and I was
it but I was just so surprised I was
talking about it I was like guys this is
like the worst costume ever I don't
deserve this attention the Kim Won
however was more of it yes the cape one
was very creative you were talking about
Canada's other famous Justin and the
first famous Justin was Justin Bieber
obviously I'm gonna take you obviously
at the time where you were asked that
question right on the court and stuff
and they asked you who your crush was
and you said Justin Bieber is he still
your crush for sure I mean really yeah I
mean he's I loved his story I've had the
chance to meet him a couple of times and
I think he's genuinely such a nice
person and I think there's so much
talent as well and you know I mean my
sister's we we would listen to his music
you know as soon as he started becoming
famous we we started following him and
things like that so it's it's kind of a
thing almost from childhood a bit so
it's he'll always be there yeah he'll
always be your first love